VIDEOTAPE WAS CUED UP.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE PRESS
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH ME.
LET’S STATUE OF LIBERTY WITH THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUE AND WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN PHILADELPHIA.
YET ANOTHER CITY.
DEMOCRAT LED CITY IN AMERICA.
THOSE ARE JUST THE FACTS THAT
HAS TURNED INTO NIGHTS OF
VIOLENCE.
>> IT’S HEART BREAKING.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTS
PEOPLE RIGHT TO PEACEFULLY
ASSEMBLE.
THAT’S NOT RIOTING AND LOOTING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE PRESIDENT
OF SAFETY AND SECURITY AND LAW
AND ORDER.
HE IS OFFERING ASSISTANCE TO ANY
CITY WITH THIS UNREST.
WHEN KENOSHA WAS BURNING, JOE
BIDEN WAS NOT CONDEMNING THAT.
HE WENT THERE TO MAKE
A POLITICAL STATEMENT.
DEMOCRATS DIDN’T TALK ABOUT THE
LOOTING AT ALL IN THEIR
CONVENTION.
THEY KNOW THOSE PEOPLE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO VOTE FOR THEM THAN FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THIS PRESIDENT BELIEVES IN LAW
AND ORDER NOT ONLY IN WORDS BUT
IN ACTION.
DEMOCRATS STOPPED LEGISLATION IN
THE SENATE FOR BETTER POLICING
AND BETTER COMMUNITIES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO DO JUST THAT.
HE STANDS PROUDLY WITH THE MEN
AND WOMEN OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> Harris: PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO
BEING ASKED A LOT ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE ARE SEEING IT.
IT’S TOUGH.
BECAUSE IN PLACES -- YOU
MENTIONED KENOSHA AND I LIVED
NEXT DOOR IN MINNESOTA.
THE HOSPITALIZATIONS AND RUNNING
OUT OF BEDS IN WISCONSIN IS
TOUGH.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT’S
CLOSING MESSAGE ON CORONAVIRUS.
ON THE STUMP IT CAN BE
DIFFERENT.
HE IS ALMOST TAUNTING SAYING
COVID, COVID, COVID.
WHAT IS HIS CLOSING MESSAGE?
>> WELL, THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
THE PRESIDENT FOUGHT TO PROTECT
MILLION OF AMERICAN LIVES.
WE KNOW JOE BIDEN WOULD HAVE
BEEN LEAP YEARS BEHIND WHERE THE
PRESIDENT IS IN ADDRESSING THE
VIRUS.
IT’S HARD FOR DEMOCRATS TO
REMEMBER.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT MADE THE
STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS HE
MENTIONED THE CORONAVIRUS.
I KNOW NANCY PELOSI PULLED HER
POLITICAL STUNT, BUT IT HAPPENED
THEN.
THE PRESIDENT SURGED RESOURCES
PPE AND VENTILATORS AND
THERAPEUTICS.
THE PRESIDENT STOOD UP THE
LARGEST PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNER
AND JOE BIDEN SAID WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE IS WRONG.
HIS PLAN IS SIMILAR TO THE
PRESIDENT’S JUST STEPS BEHIND
WHICH WOULD COST AMERICAN LIVES.
THE ONLY THING JOE BIDEN WOULD
DO DIFFERENTLY WOULD NOT STOP IN
COMING FLIGHTS FROM CHINA AND WE
KNOW THAT SAVED LIVES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS FIGHTING
AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS.
JOE BIDEN IS A DISASTER WHO
WOULD HAVE PUT US IN A MUCH
WORSE POSITION VERSUS THE
INVISIBLE ENEMY.
>> Harris: WHY DID THE PRESIDENT
ALMOST MAKE FUN OF THE WORD
COVID WITH THE CROWDS?
IT’S SOMETHING THAT STANDS OUT.
>> WELL, THERE IS SO MUCH
SUCCESS IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
SO MANY THINGS THAT SHOULD BE
TALKED ABOUT AS WELL AS HIS
EXCEPTIONAL RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS.
JUST LOOK AT THE LESS THAN
A WEEK IN THE PRESIDENT’S LIFE.
THURSDAY THE PERFORMANCE VERSUS
JOE BIDEN AT THE DEBATE.
THE NEXT DAY ANOTHER MIDDLE EAST
PEACE DEAL.
ONE OF THREE HE DELIVERED TO
MAKE THE WORLD A SAFER PLACE.
ON MONDAY, JUSTICE AMY CONEY
BARRETT WHERE NATIONAL NETWORKS
WERE NOT COVERING HER BEING
SWORN IN AS A MOM,
A CONSERVATIVE AND
A CONSTITUTIONALIST TO THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS GOING
ON IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT ALL
OF THEM.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GET TO
WOMEN VOTERS.
FIRST FROM JOE BIDEN ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT’S PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
I WILL GET YOUR REACTION AND WE
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT TOPIC.
>> HE MAKES A LOT OF BIG
PRONOUNCEMENTS BUT THEY DON’T
HOLD UP.
HE GETS HIS PHOTO-OP AND GETS
OUT.
LEAVES EVERYONE ELSE TO SUFFER
THE CONQUENCE OF HIS FAILURE TO
MAKE A RESPONSIBLE PLAN.
IT SEEMS LIKE HE JUST DOESN’T
CARE MUCH ABOUT IT.
THE LONGER HE IS IN CHARGE, THE
MORE RECKLESS HE GETS.
IT’S ENOUGH.
IT’S TIME TO CHANGE.
>> Harris: ERIN?
>> 47 YEARS OF JOE BIDEN’S
FAILURE IS NOT A CHANGE ANYBODY
IN THIS COUNTRY SHOULD WANT.
WE KNOW WHAT JOE BIDEN’S
RESPONSE LOOKS LIKE TO
A PANDEMIC AND IT’S ABYSMAL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP STOOD UP AGAINST
THE CHINESE CORONAVIRUS TO MAKE
SURE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN SAFELY
LIVE IN IN COUNTRY AND MAKE SURE
WE HAVE PPE AND VENTILATORS.
WE WILL HAVE A VACCINE IN RECORD
TIME AND GET IT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR FREE BECAUSE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN LIKES TO TRY TO TAKE
CHEAP SHOTS IN A SPEECH BUT WE
KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP FOUGHT FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ON THIS.
AND WE KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
DOESN’T BELIEVE IN THAT.